I want to talk about the benefits of
alpha lipoic acid now what is alpha
lipoic acid well your body makes it and
you can get it as a supplement it's in
certain foods as well it's in red meat
it's in certain vegetables now when
you're taking it as a supplement you're
getting a lot more of it like a thousand
times more of it than your body can make
but alpha lipoic acid is a very powerful
antioxidant and in your body you have
networks of antioxidants so when one
antioxidant does its job and it donates
an electron to this free radical which
is an unpaired electron so it's helped
stabilizes this free radical it will
borrow an electron from another
antioxidant so alpha lipoic acid is
always helping other antioxidants like
glutathione and vitamin E to help them
recharge so it helps rejuvenate other
antioxidants so antioxidants are
scavengers for free radicals so they
basically kind of the act as a sponge to
soak up free radicals and so let's say
for example you're diabetic and you have
high levels of glucose alpha lipoic acid
will protect the tissues from that or
let's say you have damage within your
mitochondria and you have this excess
production of oxidation it's called
gross
alpha lipoic acid can help counter that
so no matter if the oxidation is coming
in from the outside as in certain types
of chemicals or whatever or being
produced by your own body from this own
your own cells like in hydrogen peroxide
or other types of compounds that give
free radicals so this compound is
designed to protect that oxidation from
that now alpha lipoic acid it can also
act as a key later to help detoxify
mercury from the body now mercury in the
body it will also produce oxidation and
so will other heavy metals
well alpha lipoic acid can help counter
that and help to chelate it so it'll
connect onto it or bind and pull it out
of the body so it's really good for
mercury detox
and it's a lipid antioxidant so it's
really good for areas of your body that
are aligned with lipids as in nerves the
nerves are lined with a lipid or a fat
layer called myelin
so if someone has MS for example which
is an autoimmune condition alpha lipoic
acid would be really good to minimize
the side effects from that condition
it's also good for diabetic neuropathy
anything involving nerve damage I've
done other videos on other remedies like
benfotiamine
which is a type of that side will be one
which is really good for peripheral
neuropathies but if you were to add
alpha lipoic acid with benfotiamine
together and you had peripheral
neuropathy you would feel really good
really fast and fYI Germany has approved
alpha lipoic acid for neuropathies for
many many years so this compound
counters oxidation free radicals it
crosses the blood-brain barrier it
protects the myelin sheath it also can
help the mitochondria to make more
energy so it has a lot of different
functions some people take it to lower
their a1c because it supports healthy
blood sugars and the last thing is if
you're going to take it I recommend
taking 600 milligrams three times a day
don't take it with meals take it an
empty stomach it'll work a lot better
because it competes with food and I know
some people are gonna ask what brand do
I get I don't have a specific
recommendation on that you're gonna have
to do your own research so if you want
more knowledge on how to create a
healthy body subscribe now and get daily
notifications